governors across the country are taking
very different approaches to spiking
coveted numbers
republican governor pete ricketts
continues to leave most of the decisions
up to his citizens and their businesses
rather than lock down his state
unilaterally he joins us now from omaha
good to see you sir we appreciate it
uh looking at the employment rates now
uh because so much of this is economic
and the balance between
health and economic health nebraska's
unemployment rate 3 percent
nationally 6.9
how much of that is due to the fact that
you've allowed businesses to continue to
stay open
and make their own decisions well i
think a lot of it go the credit goes to
nebraskans who are working very hard
because we
that's part of who we are we got a great
work ethic here you know our key
industries are agriculture
and manufacturing so those have not been
as impacted by the pandemic as maybe
some
service economies or entertainment
economies and what we have done is try
to strike that balance between
slowing down the spread of the virus and
letting people live a more normal life
governor i remember having you on in the
beginning of the pandemic
as we were worried about supply chains
specifically meat packing plants
and i know covet numbers are spiking
in nebraska pretty significantly as they
are around the country
are we going to go back to a situation
where we might have
some real supply chain issues for meat
and other products that
are produced in nebraska no not at all
we took steps in the spring to work with
all of our food processing plants
to change the way they operate we
published a
coven 19 meat processors handbook for
example
that talks about the best practices to
be able to with air handling
and masks and spacing and screening and
all that
and what we've seen is we've been able
to really manage this uh in our food
processing plants
frankly it looks better than the
population at all
and we are in nebraska seeing that our
cases are down 25 percent
over the last couple weeks and our
hospitalizations are down 17
so we're hopeful we're kind of over the
hump here right now we still have to
manage this
but things are getting better
things are getting better perhaps in
nebraska around the country there's
there's big issues and
a number of your other governors are not
taking the same approach you are
especially as it relates to what
businesses they are allowed open listen
to this exchange from a couple of days
ago on cnbc about
the difference between restrictions on
big box stores and
places like lowe's and home depot versus
i live in an restaurants where there's a
lot of restaurants that have fought back
and they don't have any problems
and they're open okay you don't have to
believe it but let me just say this
you're doing a disservice to the viewer
because the viewers need to understand
the differences
you are you are i
i i'm sorry i'm sorry if if i i would
like to keep our viewers as healthy as
humanly possible
the idea of packing people into
restaurants i think our viewers are
smart enough
[Music]
it brings up this sort of philosophical
difference an important point
what is it and why is it that you view
uh
that nebraskans are able to make
decisions on their own
that perhaps in california the governor
there doesn't seem to believe
that his citizens are either smart
enough or careful enough or responsible
enough
to make decisions on their own well i
mean one of the great things about our
country
is that we have the states that can make
decisions and they're closer to their
people than
the federal government would be so you
get uh
leaders that are going to be more
responsive to their people and make
decisions based upon what's right
president trump has largely allowed
governors to make their own decisions
without really putting his hand on the
scale very much
did a little bit in the beginning since
then uh has not
are you worried that a biden
administration may take a different
approach and you're going to be forced
with making some tough decisions if
federal aid dollars are tied to certain
coveted restrictions
well i think that that is actually one
of the things that a future bite
administration could choose to do
uh i think that would be a mistake for
the buying administration i think one of
the things that the
trump administration understood is that
when it comes to managing emergencies it
really is up to the states it's not
up to the federal government real quick
would you be would you
but it does does it does it worry you
that the buy administration might do
something like that if you thought about
how you would respond in a situation of
a national mass mandate or some kind of
you know power of the purse move by the
biden administration
well we would certainly work to convince
the new administration
that that is not in their best interest
that it's not the best interest of the
country or the state to be able to do
that
i mean again i will to point out that
under the obama administration
they cross the line with regard to their
authority
numerous times and we took them to court
and were very successful in suing them
to prevent the overstep of their
authority and you know if we had to do
the same thing we will do that again
stay tuned perhaps the best way to sum
that up governor we appreciate you
taking the time on a saturday our best
to you and your family sir great thanks
very much good to see you